tell me a secret about this look tonight
tell me what a secret about this look
tonight well the secret is that I looked
at this dress on the hanger and said
there is no way that's going to
fly
and and then I put it on and I went
snatch
you did it huh
it's like a million hands holding me in
you are rocking it so I said you know
what maybe it never again in my life
because my boss Quinta Brunson my
daughter said she gets mad when I let
the girls out to play too much but I
said you know what this might be the
last time in my life but I'm getting a
boyfriend is that what we're manifesting
here at the Critics Choice Awards why
not let's get a man yeah I love that
Brad Pitt's single isn't he uh-huh all
right it's what you deserve you guys
were really Starstruck by Brad at the
Globes huh we were we all were well I
knew where he was and so to Quinta but
Janelle who was a big fan did not know
so when she saw she was like oh
there and I was like she really likes
you yeah I said he is sitting right she
no she said oh Brad Pitt's here I said
he's sitting right there and she said oh
ish oh okay and that's what she said not
Lisa Ann Walter are trying to match make
okay Janelle and Brad I see it yeah yeah
buddy uh real quick I was talking to
Cheryl the cast no matter where you guys
go look like you have the most fun and
it's all genuine yes 100 true I just I
think that we really
lucky that we are doing this great show
all of us have a a beautiful opportunity
to shine we support each other we love
when we see moments that our cast names
do that we maybe didn't see on set and
then we see it on on TV when the show
airs and then we text each other and go
oh my God you killed me like I'm still
laughing at the Quinta beat running down
the hallway with her little shoes
I mean there's just we just adore each
other and we laugh we have a good time
Cheryl is very uh circumspect she'll sit
and be very nice and attentive and then
I'll whisper horrible things in her ear
I do I'll sit behind her and be like oh
you know she's not wearing a girdle or
something like that just something
terrible what do we have to do to get
Ana gasteyer Catherine hunt and you and
the project together everybody is hoping
to happen no I saw that on I saw the
Twitter the viral Twitter piece saying
oh they have to be in a movie together
it would make eight dollars but I think
and then all the gays came on saying no
no we'll make it a hit so I'm like let's
do it let's do it on Netflix or Hulu
let's do it out why not yeah and but
then they tried to make Jennifer
Coolidge the mother I'm like she's not
old enough stop
[Music]